des permanences d'installation mensuel
pour préparer les médecins à la pratique
libérale un moyen de remédier au
problème des zones sous denses
cette praticienne remplace actuellement
deux médecins sur versailles et le ch
est née elle a décidé de s'installer
avec une consoeur cette réunion nous
aide à savoir quelles procédures
engagées dans quel ordre surtout parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'intervenants a
rencontré avant l'installation
définitive est parfois un peu flou il
faut effectivement aider à
l'installation il faut donner envie aux
internes en médecine de faire de la
médecine de ville qui n'a rien à voir
avec la médecine hospitalière alors il
ya maintenant beaucoup plus de stages en
cabinet libéral qu'auparavant mais moi
c'est vraiment mon stage de médecine
libérale qui m'a donné envie à près de
m'installer promouvoir l'activité
libérale en accompagnant les médecins
dans leur projet l'objectif de ces
réunions individuelles des conseils de
l' agence régionale de santé de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé de
l'ordre des médecins et de l'assurance
maladie
il ya quand même des projets assez
émouvante sont pas très loin de votre
notre lieu d'installation prévu je vous
dis juste si jamais cela que vous
correspondre il ya des aides ça peut
vous permettre de démarrer si nous avons
un médecin qui a vraiment un projet très
stabiliser les conseils vont pas être
les mêmes qu'un médecin qui va nous
parler d'une commune effectivement le
rôle de la herray cela va être de mettre
de faire le lien avec les communes qui
sont en demande de médecins donc il me
contacter par téléphone portable par
mail et on les accompagne jusqu'au
moment de leur installation voir un
petit peu après quand ils ont des
questions très concrètes ça peut être
sur les démarches administratives mais
ça peut être aussi sur des questions
personnelles par rapport à leur charge
personnelle au dossier d'accessibilité
pour les locaux toute question relative
à leur installation
ces permanences et existe depuis 2012 en
ile de france dans les yvelines 67
médecins ont été reçus 45 sont installés
parmi eux huit exerce sur saint quentin
en yvelines dont trois généralistes la
qualité de vie un critère de choix pour
le lieu d'exercice des professionnels de
santé
nous avons la population médicale qui
sait féminise
et il faut donc pour la femme médecin
elle a besoin d'avoir une crèche elle a
besoin d'avoir des écoles
elle a besoin si pour s'occuper de sa
vie familiale que tout ça soit à
disposition autour d'elle et autour de
son exercice
l'agencé régionale de santé vise aussi
des étudiants en médecine avec le
contrat d'engagement de service public
le financement des études en échange
d'un engagement d'installation dans une
zone sous denses